guten tag meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen an der landes bei
der regiovhs akademie am institut für
höhere militärische führung mein name
ist obersberg holzner und ich bin deine
klara zweite des referats führungslehre
ein bisschen mäßigen warum wir uns wie
in den nächsten minuten unterhalten
wollen ist täglich in der ukraine und
zwar genau überführungen
führungsfähigkeit als den entscheidenden
faktor in einem umfeld das die dynamik
unvorhersehbarkeit und komplexität
geprägt ist
lassen sie uns nun einige beobachtungen
im bereich verfügung machen ich möchte
mit der russischen seite beginnen und
dort genauer mit dem kommandanten
verhalten darum zwischen kommandant der
russischen kommandanten folgen
offensichtlich im prinzip das führen von
vorne selbst höchste dienst gerade
bisschen die general ränge werden direkt
an der front angetroffen die russischen
kommandanten befinden sich auch dort
wurde schwergewicht begleichen sowie
entscheidung gesucht an und für sich ist
das nicht ungewöhnlich was allerdings
schon ungewöhnlich ist ist das sehr
hoher see ranghoher und sicher kann man
daten sehr und mit wortsinn wo das gerät
geschenkt stattfindet und sich dadurch
natürlich auch gefährden warum ist das
so hierüber können wir nur mutmaßen
es gibt allerdings einige indizien die
dafür sprechen
der mister folgende gesamten
operationsführung so dass auch ranghohe
kommandanten genötigt werden unmittelbar
an der front einfluss zu nehmen gepaart
ist das ganze mit einem möglichen
vertrauens mangel quer über die gesamte
russische philosophie so dass
kommandanten wieder vorne ein blick von
der einfluss nehmen müssen weil sie in
unser leben nicht vertrauen und ein
weiterer aspekt könnte aber dürfte die
schlechte moral der gesamten russischen
streitkräfte seien wiederum sind hier
hochrangige kommen dazu angehalten durch
persönliches erscheinen
an der front diese schlechte moral zu
geben
das manifest scheint sind die probleme
in der führungsunterstützung auf
russischer seite das bedeutet das
herstellen einer gesicherten verbindung
zwischen kommandanten gefegt ständen und
anderen für uns ein
deswegen sind die russischen
kommandanten auch sie erhielt dazu
angehalten ungeschützte
kommunikationsmittel und mobiltelefone
zu nehmen zu verwenden können da wir
auch leicht aufgewertet
lassen sie uns nun auf die ukrainische
seite blicken hier ist das
ausgezeichnete lagebildes wesentlicher
aspekt für die ukrainische führung
anzusprechen
offensichtlich wird sehr viel satelliten
und luftaufklärung betrieben gar nicht
nur im rheinischen eigenen mitteln
sondern und mit unterstützung und
rückgriffen auf marco ersetzt
insbesondere scheint die direkte
satelliten und nutzt auch der
unterstützung durch die usa mannes zu
sein außerdem sogenanntes sieg in signal
intelligence also die möglichkeit
elektronische elektromagnetische signale
zu horten standorte festzustellen
inhalte abzuhören und damit auch
kommandanten unsicher kommandanten an
geschäftsleute sie zukommt die
beeinträchtigung es fehlt also die
möglichkeit sicher führungsunterstützung
stören oder zum verbrechen und last but
not least auch eine entsprechende wird
fähigkeit und dieses lagebild auch aus
tun
was bedeuten dass nun auch dem
gefechtsfeld wie sich ihr dieser grafik
sehen können sind inzwischen bis zu
einem viertel der top-führungskräfte das
sind generals ränge im einsatzraum der
ukraine ausgefallen also von etwa 20
eingesetzten russischen generieren sind
zu mindestens fünf inzwischen gefallen
beispielsweise der kommandant und der
chef des stabes der 41 das ist eine
armee die in norton im bereich kann
gefängnis sitzt wird und nur diese armee
komplett führungslos wurde der
kommandant 29 der im nordwesten der
ukraine eingesetzt ist so wie der
kommandant der 150 schützen division
wären 15 3 mario pohl direkt an der
front gefallen ist und der kommandant
der achten armee der ebenfalls erst
letzten samstag am 19 im süden gefallen
ist zusätzlich dazu sind mindestens 13
oberste das sind banden von taktischen
regions- kampfgruppen fernmelde
verbänden oder anderen einheiten
inzwischen gefallen was heißt das nun
aus nicht mehr führung das heißt
folgendes was auf russischer seite ein
ganz wesentliches führungs prinzip
nämlich die eigene führung zu schützen
offensichtlich nicht erfüllt werden kann
auch beim rheinischen seite ein genauso
gewesen wie führen wenn sie nämlich den
führungsfähigkeiten des gegners
beeinträchtigen zu minimieren
offensichtlich sehr sehr erfolgreich
jetzt könnte man sich fragen ob es
zufall ist dass so viele russische
führungskräfte ausgeschaltet werden bei
youtube.de ziele festzulegen und
führungskräfte gefechten der führungs
einrichtungen sind nun einmal
qualitätsziele gibt es ein international
standardisiertes verfahren das
sogenannte targeting verfahren dass ich
mal ganz kurz erläutern dass dagegen
verfahren ist ein pendant zur festlegung
und bekämpfung von privates ziel und
gliedert sich in vier phasen die grüne
phase entscheiden wo wir die ziele
festgelegt werden zum beispiel
kommandanten oder für uns ein richtig
die gelbe farbe aufklären gepäck wo die
neue lage und zieldaten dieser modestil
festgestellt werden um diese ziele auch
getrackt also verfolgt werden gegenüber
die blaue phase wirkten die leber wo
eine entsprechende waffenwirkung auf
diese ziele ausgeübt wird um dann in der
roten phase großaufgaben es
festzustellen um diese wirkung auch im
ziel gelegen ist falls sie nicht im ziel
gelegen ist jedes weiter mit der phase
aufklärung und erneuten bieten wie nur
dieser marketing zyklus anhand eines
generischen beispiel ist in der ukraine
stattfinden könnte mag ich ihnen auf der
nächsten folie zeiten
stellen sie sich folgendes gerät zum
beispiel vor eine russische motorisierte
schützen regal hier die zweite
interessierte schützen begann rot
eingezeichnet am rechten bildrand zu
sehen hat einen gelände abschnitten
ukraine eingenommen und sich dort
zurzeit wichtigsten verteidigung
eingerichtet eine ukrainische gegen
angriffskraft hier ist die vision
eingezeichnet innerhalb der ukrainischen
flagge hat den auftrag
in dieses dispositiv einzubrechen und
den eingebrochenen bande zerschlagen
nun erfolgte phase entscheiden die seit
und seit einiger zeit wird beurteilt
welche ziele in diesem russischen
dispositiv buchwert ziele und moritz
thiele darstellen damit ziele der
lokalisierung und bekämpfung im
wesentlichen erfolg der eigenen 1
satzführung beeinflussen sie zu wird
festgestellt dass der gefechtsstand der
zweiten motorisierten schützen auf
russischer seite vor ein problem
darstellt wir sind jetzt in begrünen
phase entscheiden sie sehen diesen
bestand blauer engel in der nächsten
phase auf gegebenenfalls unter rückgriff
auf satelliten aufklärungsmittel mit
unterstützung der usa möglicherweise
werden die genauen lage umziehen daten
dieses gefechtsstand festgestellt um in
der nächsten phase blau wirken deliver
möglicherweise unter einsatz einer
drohne genau jenen gefechtsstand
auszuschalten und dann anschließend in
der gruppenphase übungsaufgaben es
möglicherweise wieder mit sehr beliebt
auch wehren oder mit anderen umgebunden
aufklärungsmittel denn erfolge
festzustellen
offensichtlichen ukrainischen geräte in
diesen tagen den zyklus insbesondere
dass das ausschalten von führungskräften
und ständen betrifft sehr sehr
erfolgreich wie die vorherigen folien
mit den hohen ausfällen von kommandanten
russischer seite uns bereits gezeigt
werden
was bedeutet das nun was hat das für
auswirkungen auf stimmung zwischen
eintreffenden kräfte der russischen
kräfte sind durch das ausschalten
wesentliche elemente der führen mitten
ins herz getroffen können wo man sein
das sind einerseits sehr viele einsatz
erfahrene kommandanten verloren gegangen
und darüber hinaus wesentliche führungs
einrichtungen zerschlagen worden was
bedeutet dies nun zusammengefasst
zusammengefasst bedeutet das eine
deutliche reduktion der führungsleistung
auf russischer seite einerseits führt
der verlust vieler einsatz erfahrener
kommandanten dazu dass die qualität der
führungs entscheidungen ziehen
einerseits für die zerstörung von
wesentlichen führungs entscheidungen
dazu dass auch die geschwindigkeit der
aufbereitung von führungs grundlagen und
damit die geschwindigkeit funktions
entscheidungen so
zusammengefasst bleibt zu beobachten ob
all diese geschehen ist eine anpassung
der russischen führungsprinzipien mit
sich bringe zum beispiel was die lage
von gefecht stellen betrifft was den
einsatz von kommandanten direkt an der
fortbetrieb oder was insbesondere den
schutz von führungs anregungen
kommandanten betrifft wie zum beispiel
das nicht verwenden ungeschützter
mobiltelefonie und dagegen das verwenden
geschütz der kommunikationsmittel
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
und bis zum nächsten mal